foreign
[Music]
Quick Fix analyzing Tech Solutions
Solutions
let me start with the definition what is
tax solutionism tax solutionism is the
tendency to use technology to solve a
societal political organizational
environmental what have you problem
a few examples should make this more
clear example number one riots
what's the problem
well suppressed population groups for
example ethnic minorities are starting
to mobilize
what do we observe
this is more likely to happen when it's
hot very hot
what is the solution
well just install climatization
throughout
and what do we gain
we don't have to actually address those
groups as demands
example two mass shootings what is the
problem since 2014 on average there has
been more than one month shooting a day
in the U.S
what do we observe
you can't always see if someone is
carrying a gun
what's the solution
I just installed Advanced surveys
technology
and what do we gain we don't have to
change the laws related to gun ownership
example number three
climate change
what is the problem
climate change is rendering parts of the
earth inhabitable and strongly impacts
living conditions and others
what's our observation
time is passing and we are less and less
on track to keep the situation under
control
what's the solution
or we just moved to Mars or somewhere
else in space
what do we gain why we survive and get
her fun well if that's the kind of thing
we find fun right
so
yeah I think by now it should be pretty
clear what I'm talking about here
on the other hand you probably also have
noticed I got more and more into some
kind of cynical tone like disgust
cynicism
and pure cynicism and just talking that
way doesn't bring us very far why well
on the one hand we won't notice less
blatant so the solutions quote unquote
when it's less clear like for example
talking about climate change what about
things like geoengineering isn't that
easy and also we're not never gonna
reach those people who don't already
agree with us anyway right so I don't
think this is very useful
on the other hand I think we what we
should try is to understand what is so
seductive about this thing
well
like the word already says it solves
something good right
it solves a problem
often it solves a hard problem
a problem that otherwise we would know
how to solve how to address even
it solves a problem we would have to
make sacrifices for and we don't want
that right
and often it just solves a problem we're
terribly scared about
so
what I'm going to try to in this talk is
or what I think we need some kind of
framework to analyze those proposals and
a framework which does not just ask the
technical questions because this is
something we are already doing to some
degree
um but I think the technical aspect is
not enough
and so I'm going to try to propose a
very simple framework a framework of w
questions like what where when why who
to whom how it's not a w anyway
but uh to address this in a certain
medical way and there I'm going to focus
on the more neglected aspects so but as
I'm gonna focus on two of these aspects
let me say what I mean by the rest of
them
first what
what does the solution do
and this should include the complete
technical workflow like from where do we
get the data from how do we train our
machine learning models how do we
evaluate them and in this area we
already have some things like a data set
documentation model documentation which
is all great but which is all the
technical side of things
then where when and to whom will the
solution be applied and this should
include the complete Geographic
geographical social political Etc
context
then how will the solution be applied
and here will be the details matter
next who is implementing the solution
there as you see I want to talk about
more and also why is the solution being
developed there are also I would like to
go into some detail so in other words in
this talk I want to go into the why and
the who because in my view these are the
two aspects which are being neglected
most in this area first let's start with
the Y
so what kind of things you're going to
hear well we care
we want to help
we are here for you
what kind of things won't you hear in
this area and here I'm kind of splitting
it up a bit first what kind of reasons
might individual people have when they
Implement something or suggest something
which they won't say
well for example
if I build this thing it's going to go
look on my resume
if I am with this thing it might just
get me a job at company XYZ
if I built this thing
um I might be able to will create a
startup
if I built this thing
I'm gonna let learn that crazy new
technology X
and also
it's just so cool that this can even be
done
next in a more indirect way
what uh no organization when
organizations do something they propose
something what are the things they don't
say
well if we built this we are going to
strengthen our existing Market Monopoly
if we build this we're going to distract
from that bad thing that recently went
through the news
if we build this we're gonna be the good
guys
and now in a more indirect way let's
think about side effects
if we build this we are going to be able
to extract valuable data for our
targeted advertising
if we bought this we are going to get
data to feedback into our neural
networks
if we build this we're going to have the
foot in the door
if
we build this
public institutions will be stuck with
us
now let's step up one level and think
this is about technology
and technology is something that shapes
us that forms us our daily lives
if we build this we Define how people
live
if we build this we Define how people
think
if we build this we Define what people
feel
if we build this we Define who people
are
by now I think it should be clear what I
mean by motivations by this thing so why
things are built
now let's switch to the next thing the
who who built something
and here I want to be a bit more clear
from the outset who I'm talking about
because this can be a bit ambiguous who
could also mean like to whom the
solution is being applied I'm not
talking about that aspects right now
what I mean is spelling it out who
designs implements and hosts the
solution
who processes its data
who knows how it works and can fix
problems
so
let's take an example I'm going to as an
example I'm going to talk about
education technology also abbreviated as
attack
which has been booming a lot over the
last years especially of course due to
the pandemic
and okay with attack what kind of things
are you gonna hear
well with adaptive technology XYZ
individual Learners needs are being met
with adaptive technology XYZ teachers
can focus on doing or what they do best
with technology XYZ we make learning
more effective and efficient
what kind of things won't you hear
how it works
with technology XYZ we're gonna extract
store and process lots of very private
and personal data
with technology XYZ we are constantly
monitoring your behavior
with technology XYZ you learn we are
learning from you
now this is about education technology
what's education education is like
forming people shaping young people
yeah forming people let's just say like
this so what this really means like is
we Define how people learn
how do we Define what is learned
we Define what deserves to be learned
we Define what deserves to be forgotten
and stepping up a level some somehow a
bit more abstract what is learned common
knowledge
this is building a culture this is like
who we are so
what does this mean
we Define the past
we Define the present
we Define the future
we Define what it means to be human
okay right now you may be wondering
can you say again how this is about the
who
yeah and so before I was saying what I
mean by who is who designs implements
and tells the solution
who processes and stores the data
and who knows how it works
this who
or let's say like these whose we can put
them on a dimension
and here I want to ask you
to go with me and imagine a dimension
a continuous Dimension with on the one
hand we have the public and on the other
hand we have the private
on the one hand for the public
institution I'm asking you to imagine an
ideal democracy we all know there is no
ideal democracy but we can all strive
for one at least hopeful one perhaps
so on the one this idea democracy on the
other hand for the private institutions
this can be anything can be a
cooperation a foundation an NGO it
doesn't really matter the official
status
what are defining features of these hoos
on that dimension
for the ideal democracy we have a
democratic decision process with
participation ranging on top
for the private part end of the
dimension we can only say what's lacking
like this Democratic decision process
otherwise could be anything
what are defining values
for the public institution these are
things like fairness Justice human
rights accountability for the private
institution again it will depend on that
institution's agenda
so now if I assume this dimension of who
what kind of difference would that make
well for one public institutions don't
have to gather data to make money
public institutions don't have to keep
their Trade Secrets
public institutions don't need to worry
about Market position
next what difference does this make in
political and legal respects
public institutions can be held to
ensure transparency
public institutions can be held to be
can be held accountable
public institutions can be obliged to be
fair
and again stepping a bit about stepping
up a bit in abstractness
what difference does it make to a human
rights and values
public institutions can be held to
prioritize values over feasibility
public institutions can be obliged to
respect human rights
public institutions can be held to
promote not erase individuality
now you may be wondering still I'm not a
CEO
what can I do
well I don't really know but
I think
one thing is perhaps we can make choices
this will depend
perhaps we can make choices like who we
work for
what we vote for
whether we organize politically
or one step back perhaps even
We can question the things we are being
told pretty much in the spirit of this
talk asking questions
or even perhaps only we can
start with a bit of imagination
maybe data science could be different
what if
data were used not to perpetuate but
change the status quo
what if data we used to make social
relations more egalitarian more just
what if data were used to subvert
privileges not reinforce them
thank you very much for your attention
[Music]